hey guys Justin I was telling myself to
see you gotta stop you gotta cut down on
the iPhone videos beginning you got a
new iPhone and everybody knows that but
the new a Century City Apple store just
opened up the day at the iPhone 10 came
out so it's driving past and I decided
that I need to come and check it out I
came here to this Apple store I think it
waits in line for an iPad at some point
I cut too that's what I'm getting I'm
getting the pink one
not really sure where it's at this is
all new but they just recently reopened
up this mall so everything is brand new
I've never seen you so where's the here
it is I didn't even recognize a because
there's no big Apple logo anywhere the
only Apple logo is over here that I
could see which is kind of crazy because
it's super bright that I really didn't
even see it push my iPhone now because
this camera just died so welcome to the
life of vlogging behind me is the new
Apple Store let's get it exposed so
there it is there's the Apple logo
[Applause]
right there
[Music]
it's so quiet in here this reminds me a
lot of the one in New York that they
have with this huge screen
this is awesome and they have like a
little needed Apple area you can sit
right here and learn and hang out I want
to see something on this screen look at
this we're doing a live art with Simon
I've got Rowan a puzzle
[Music]
how do i buy them it's so crazy I
couldn't figure out how to get a case
and only got a do you pull this open and
the right here it's like magic
so the new Apple store is really really
nice but I just got home and I texted
Matt and Jenna I said hey you guys and
play call of duty and that's it we
should all have a LAN party and I got
really excited I told everybody to come
here my internet kind of sucks but in
fact on my xbox and I'm gonna go we're
gonna have nice land part it's gonna be
great it's the food one of the things
that's a problem though is Matt plays
mostly on playstation because he's a pro
player and most of the pros all play on
playstation they used to play on xbox
but then now they're all on PlayStation
which is unfortunate the past two years
I switched back over to PlayStation to
play call of duty and then I realized
that I never actually ever play with a
pro player so it really doesn't matter
so this year I'm playing called did you
back when Xbox like it doesn't even
matter if I have a 4k Xbox or not
because I play on really small monitors
it's all about the refresh rate baby
let's go yes it does everything is just
going swimmingly do you see this this is
my first smartphone I'm gonna do a video
soon reacting to some of the things that
I have on here I did plug it in and I
was pretty shocked future video you
might bring this one this whole past
week has basically been iPhone week and
I have non-stop and shooting and editing
videos it's pretty time-consuming so
today I'm gonna treat myself we're gonna
be playing some games called dude he
came out a few days ago these are the
best hard drives ever other the samsung
solid-state drives
no I'm pretty vapor flip my switch in
here I might have to bring another bag
one for Jenna let's see maybe I'll bring
one for Matt to check out this sweet
wine fridge look how much wine I have
hmm gonna have to work on the wine
selection one of Jenna's friends and
neighbors was moving out and they
couldn't fit their wine fridge in the
truck to take it with him so I was like
I'll take that off your hands I gotcha
I got you
I got line I don't have much okay we
gotta go we gotta go I'm picking up some
goodies for our land party Jenna said to
get popcorn these though
classic salted sounds good great
and it get settle on a line this one
right here has a little pig on it so
it's got to be good
genuine I always loved no one ever I
forgot I was vlogging - so it's 1247 we
played a lot of calls judy ate a lot of
snacks not really sure if the LAN party
was a success I think it wasn't he me
and Jenna play dad was working Matt sort
of late eats a cupcake drink soda and
had great stories and conversational
exchanges we had a great time we did we
do good dialogue or great dialogue I
could say we had great dialogue no yeah
we got a we got to walk the dog and I
got to go home because I've got a lot of
stuff to pack up eat your cupcake at I'm
so upset why is it either right now I'm
stream I mean on film it's okay you
don't have to just you know you've long
and I mean I mean well I'm filming
that's my breakfast I'm talking that was
really sassy
so yes Matt I'm glad I'm so sleepy I was
just watching Matt's video that we fell
into last night before we had our
wonderful LAN party today I kind of took
the day off because last week it was
insane with iPhone week I basically
didn't sleep at all for a week I was
shooting and editing just pretty much
non-stop trying to get content out for
you guys about the iPhone cuz obviously
the iPhone
is like the one time of year I guess
this year we were graced with two times
a year yesterday I went to Century City
the new mall and I was like guys you
gotta go to this mall it looks great
it's awesome so today we're going back
so this vlog is going to pick up
basically where this vlog started we're
going back to the mall this is Maddie
for anybody who may be new here
he's my sweet pup we rescued him two
years ago can let me have this one give
me this spit good so we're gonna see
movie Matt you know comes here to pick
me up and he's like okay you're driving
I'm like wait what just let me drive you
I promise
everywhere why don't you trust me to
drive your car Oh check out that wise
bridge I think I showed you guys it but
I'm really excited about it okay hey
take a look at how much wine I have in
there looks good though probably just
put bottles of water that's actually a
great idea quick they'd be a nice
temperature cuz it's not too cold
okay let's go to the theater I guess I'm
driving dinner do you want me to drive
your mom yeah just back into a hole that
wasn't row she wanted you guys the
update and Matt in the back seat yelling
yelling about our not yelling a park you
need to punch it gently because then we
can't find our call we have numbers and
letters sometimes they don't make sense
yeah
get out don't make sense in your head
yeah cuz my brain is developing I'm
I can see this at night because when I
was here yesterday it was really bright
and you didn't actually exceed the full
hook of the new Apple story it looks so
much better at night forget it oh yeah
this looks good this just opened up on
November 3rd this is the first day what
I love that activity
let's close the ring okay I did get up
okay have to get it oh he isn't carrying
anything that you hope for it is going
to be when I have my first accident yep
great sorry all right there it is that's
uh two trips the Apple store in two days
that's on a call
Jenna got our AppleCare now we need to
find some food
potentially do a little bit of shopping
I think you're good I hit my limit for
spending but our movie starts at 7:00 oh
we don't much time the mall the mall the
mall mall the mall
tango does the Macarena definitely is
not experience is definitely not we just
got home from seeing Thor and Matt was
saying man I really wish that I had some
new Apple watch bands well guess what I
have a bunch of watch bands for you
because I switched to the 38 and math
has the 40 to do with em take a look and
see what I got oh God wait you were not
kidding
yeah okay what color would you like I
was looking for a darker color okay well
let's see what in half we have all
bright colors sorry yeah yeah well
thanks for watching guys they showed us
a blog cuz it's been awhile since I have
actually posted a vlog vlog I've been
posting a ton of iPhone videos as you
guys know what's that part of water here
it's so easy you just see this little
button right here push that in a little
bit and then it's pretty exciting thanks
Justine you're welcome
I'm glad someone's getting use of them
wow this is great hey man he gets the
commitment come on you can put your hand
in it dude you should put your hand
underneath his toys he's innocent really
yes
[Music]